wie war dein wochenende
tippt ab am samstag 4 gearbeitet
und am sonntag war ich wandern
das war sehr schön
und wie war dein wochenende
ich hatte ein date
toll erzählt wie was
[Musik]
toll erzählt wie war's
es war leider nicht so gut
oh nein warum
also zuerst gingen wir in ein restaurant
das essen war sehr gut der wein auch
aber während des essens hatte er die
ganze zeit auf sein handy geschaut
das ist aber nicht nett
nein das war nervig
nach dem essen sind wir in eine bar
gegangen
die musik war super
es gab sogar live musik
trotzdem wollte er nicht tanzen
er meinte er könne nicht gut tanzen
schade waren die cocktails gut
ja sehr
ich hatte einen wodka lemon
er trank einen gin tonic
ja sehr
ich hatte einen wodka lemon
er trank einen gin tonic
nachdem wir aus getrunken hatten
bezahlten wir die rechnung
danach gingen wir zum bahnhof
wir mussten in die gleiche richtung
im zug ist er dann eingeschlafen
er hat so laut geschnarcht dass die
leute nebenan reklamiert haben
das ist ein bisschen peinlich
ja das war sehr peinlich
als meine haltestelle kam weckte ich ihn
auf
er war ein bisschen verschlafen
bevor ich ausstieg entschuldigte er sich
bei mir
er sagte er sei sehr müde von der arbeit
und es tue ihm leid dass er
eingeschlafen ist
bevor ich ausstieg entschuldigte er sich
bei mir
er sagte er sei sehr müde von der arbeit
und es tue ihm leid dass er
eingeschlafen ist
ich sagte dann es sei kein problem
es gebe so tage
und ich hoffe er komme gut nach hause
ich sagte dann es sei kein problem
es gebe so tage
und ich hoffe er komme gut nach hause
das war sehr lieb von dir
hast du noch etwas von ihm gehört
ja am nächsten morgen hat er
die nachricht geschickt
ja am nächsten morgen hat
nachricht geschickt
er meinte er habe den abend super
gefunden
und er würde es sehr gerne wiederholen
und willst du ihn wiedersehen
gibst du ihm noch eine chance
ich weiß nicht
er war sehr hübsch und groß und
sportlich und auch nett
aber ich fand es nicht so toll
es war irgendwie komisch
vielleicht hatte er einen schlechten tag
oder er war sehr nervös
ja vielleicht hast du recht
soll ich ihm schreiben dass er sich
gerne wieder melden darf
ja mach das
beim zweiten treffen ist er dann
möglicherweise viel entspannter
ja mach das
beim zweiten treffen ist er dann
möglicherweise viel entspannter
vielleicht könnt ihr ins kino gehen
da muss man das handy abschalten
na ja dann kann er auch nicht die ganze
zeit darauf schauen
ja dann kann er auch nicht die ganze
eine freundin meinte der neue james
blunt 008 sei super
blond 008 sei super
ah ja das erstaunt mich
denn ich habe gerade erst gelesen er
habe überhaupt keine handlung und er
wäre sehr unrealistisch und schlecht
denn ich habe gerade erst gelesen er
habe überhaupt keine handlung und er
wäre sehr unrealistisch und schlecht
ok dann vielleicht doch lieber eine
romantische komödie
[Musik]
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare
wir werden sie beantworten hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal